a comment calling our city gross has
sparked some back and forth between the
mayors of oakland and las vegas on
twitter that's right many took the
social media upset over the comment as
well joe miller spoke to some bay area
residents about this he's live on the
strip for us this afternoon and joe what
are they telling you
oh christian vanessa you know a lot of
people were offended by the comments
that the mayor of oakland made
especially people who call this city
home and who call this desert their home
many of them say that they were just
upset with the comments that she made so
today we decided to go to the airport
and talk to people flying in from the
oakland area to las vegas about those
comments and we also asked them about
the a's situation
the potential of the oakland a's moving
to las vegas continues to linger as the
waterfront stadium in oakland is still
up in the air in a few tv interviews
this week the mayor of oakland libby
chef called the las vegas desert gross
and said the city has some tacky
architecture las vegas mayor carolyn
goodman took to twitter telling shaft to
join the 42 million visitors who come
here and even invited her to a raiders
game i went to the airport and spoke to
tourists flying in from oakland about
the comments who she is as the mayor she
should probably be making comments about
other metropolitan areas so yeah no
don't don't agree with it other
travelers i spoke with say the a's need
a new stadium regardless of where it is
they should have had a stadium a long
time ago
and why don't they have a statement
and if you guys are willing to build in
the stadium they should come here
now back out here live we also did talk
to some vegas residents specifically i
talked to a handful of private drivers
they say both cities have their own
unique charm but one did mention there
is a reason more californians are moving
to las vegas reporting on the strip joe
mohler live local now